Why is a Final Performance Called a Swan Song?
When someone performs for the last time, we
often refer to it as a “swan song” which
seems odd given that swans aren’t particularly
known for their stage presence…
So where exactly did this phrase come from?
This expression is generally thought to have
its genesis in the over two thousand year
old idea that swans sing a beautiful song
just before death.
Although this is technically not accurate,
there is a hint of truth to it in select instances.
For instance, the Whooper Swan, which as its
name suggests is known for making a bizarre
honking sound, has been observed to sometimes
make a noise as it expires.
This is thought to be a byproduct of this
bird having an extremely elongated tracheal
loop combined with the way the air flows through
it as they die and their lungs expel any excess
atmosphere.
The sound this sometimes makes has been described
as being akin to “a clarionet when blown
by a novice in music”…
Not exactly beautiful song, but it is a sound
upon death at least.
Interestingly, the Whooper Swan is endemic
to Greece, leading some to speculate that
someone in Ancient Greece heard one of these
birds’ dying sounds and subsequently exaggerated
the event and attributed the same to all swans,
thus giving rise to the legend.
Perhaps the first known instance of the idea
of swans singing just before death appeared
in the six century BC in one of Aesop’s
Fables- The Swan and the Goose:
A certain rich man bought in the market a
Goose and a Swan.
He fed the one for his table and kept the
other for the sake of its song.
When the time came for killing the Goose,
the cook went to get him at night, when it
was dark, and he was not able to distinguish
one bird from the other.
By mistake he caught the Swan instead of the
Goose.
The Swan, threatened with death, burst forth
into song and thus made himself known by his
voice, and preserved his life by his melody.
Another potential candidate for the first
reference to this can be found in Aeschylus’
Agamemnon, written in 458 BC: “That is why
he lies there like this, and she does too,
his lover, after singing her last death-laden
lament like a swan.”
Despite the dates I just listed, which of
these is really first isn’t clear because
none of Aesop’s Fables were actually written
by him as all copies of “his” fable compilation
have been lost.
Since then, many fables have been falsely
credited to him, but really were simply tacked
on in the ensuing millennia and others were
re-worked to fit the precise message the teller
was going for.
(Even much of what we “know” about this
legendary storytelling slave himself is probably
itself fiction.)
The first known compilation of Aesop’s Fables
wasn’t even created until 300 BC by Demetrius
of Phalerum who, among many other things,
was the head of acquisitions at the Library
of Alexandria.
(And if you’re curious, see: What Really
Happened to the Library of Alexandria?)
This work has also since been lost.
The first surviving collections of the fables
didn’t come about until the first and second
centuries AD.
Needless to say, with a 600+ year gap between
when Aesop supposedly lived and the first
surviving collection of “his” fables,
it’s difficult to say when the story of
the Swan and the Goose was first written down,
let alone when it was first spoken.
Whatever the case, from here the notion of
swans singing just before death appeared in
countless pieces of classical literature,
poetry and music.
For instance, in Plato’s Phaedo, Plato claims
that Socrates stated,
Will you not allow that I have as much of
the spirit of prophecy in me as the swans?
For they, when they perceive that they must
die, having sung all their life long, do then
sing more than ever, rejoicing in the thought
that they are about to go away to the god
whose ministers they are.
But men, because they are themselves afraid
of death, slanderously affirm of the swans
that they sing a lament at the last, not considering
that no bird sings when cold, or hungry, or
in pain, not even the nightingale, nor the
swallow, nor yet the hoopoe; which are said
indeed to tune a lay of sorrow, although I
do not believe this to be true of them any
more than of the swans.
But because they are sacred to Apollo, and
have the gift of prophecy, and anticipate
the good things of another world, therefore
they sing and rejoice in that day more than
ever they did before.
And I too, believing myself to be the consecrated
servant of the same God, and the fellow servant
of the swans, and thinking that I have received
from my master gifts of prophecy which are
not inferior to theirs, would not go out of
life less merrily than the swans.
Numerous historical figures have since made
attempts to debunk the idea that swans sing
upon their death, such as Pliny the Elder
who wrote in the first century AD, “Observation
shows that the story that the dying swan sings
is false, judging from experience…” in
his landmark Natural History.
Nevertheless, the notion endured.
Notable instances of this include Chaucer
writing in his fourteenth century Parliament
of Foules, “The Ialous swan, ayens his deth
that singeth.
[The jealous swan, sings before his death]”
(Interestingly, this poem also includes the
first explicit Valentine’s Day / love connection.)
Even Leonardo da Vinci got into the swan song
/ death action noting, “The swan is white
without spot, and it sings sweetly as it dies,
that song ending its life.”
Shakespeare also wrote in his sixteenth century
The Merchant of Venice: “Let music sound
while he doth make his choice; then, if he
lose, he makes a swan-like end, fading in
music.”
So when did this idea of swans singing before
death morph into the specific expression “swan
song”?
The English version of this appears to have
been borrowed from the German Schwanengesang
(Swan Song), with the first known instance
of the original German version being Georg
Philipp Telemann’s 1733 concerto of the
same name.
The first recorded use of the phrase in English
didn’t appear in print until a couple decades
later when Scottish priest John Willison in
one of his Scripture Songs (Song VI) noted,
“Being a Prophecy of Christ, and King David’s
Swan Song in views of death…”
In Sermon II of his 1747 Five Sacramental
Sermons, published in The Balm of Gilead,
Willison also mirrors the sentiment in Plato’s
Phaedo, referring to a swan song upon death
being one of joy,
You may sing that swan-song, Psal. xlviii.
14, “For this God is our God for ever and
ever, and he will be our guide even unto death.”
It is this that gives a believer peace in
his latter end: it made David to triumph in
the view of approaching death…
As for how this popularly morphed into referring
to a performer’s final work or performance,
beyond a few other references very loosely
fitting the bill, the first known more explicit
instance of this was the great Franz Schubert’s
1828 Schwanengesang (Swan Song), which is
a collection of songs by Schubert written
near the end of his life and published in
1829, a year after his death at the tender
age of 31.
(Not to be confused with Johann Senn’s Schwanengesang
poem that Schubert previously put to music
in 1822.)
Schubert did not, however, name this posthumous
work.
Instead, Tobias Haslinger published the collection
under this name referencing the age-old notion
of swans singing a final, beautiful song before
expiring, with, of course, Schubert being
the swan in this case and the collection his
final “song”.